sources tell CBS News president Trump is
very likely to sign a bipartisan
spending deal it gives much less money
than he wants for barriers on the Mexico
border the agreement would end nearly
two months of gridlock and prevent
another partial government shutdown the
president told reporters he was not
happy with it at first glance Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill tracking
efforts to push the deal through Nancy
that Friday deadline is fast approaching
that's right time is of the essence and
no one here on Capitol Hill views this
as a done deal quite yet and that's
because they they're still writing the
bill and problems can always crop up
during that process and be the president
hasn't definitively said that he'll sign
it
in fact he's made it pretty clear he
doesn't like it the answer is no I'm not
President Trump may not be happy but
he's up against a united Congress I hope
he'll decide to sign it sign it and
don't cause a shutdown they're urging
him not to listen to his TV allies who
have rejected deals in the past the
so-called compromise his typical of the
DC sewer and swamp the president wanted
5.7 billion dollars for a border wall
the compromise gives him about a quarter
of it nearly one point four billion
dollars for fencing 55 miles of it in
the Rio Grande Valley Republicans say
it's a start
I don't mind him taking that as a down
payment and finding the rest do it's
active action the president's a little
bit of box because he said at one time
or another so many different things that
no matter what we sign he can somebody
can say you didn't give me one in
Hangzhou don't want the agreement is
actually slightly smaller than the 1.6
billion dollars the Senate set out in
December a sign of the leverage mr.
Trump lost after a five-week shutdown
that left 800,000 federal workers in
limbo would the president have been
better off accepting the deal that the
Senate negotiated before the shutdown I
think he's got a pretty good deal here
you know the speaker said there wouldn't
be a dollar for a wall lockets we're
gonna have an argument now about what
the wall the president's aides tell CBS
News he probably will sign the deal and
then look for more funding elsewhere
it's not doing the trick but I'm
things to it and when you end whatever I
have to add it's all it's all gonna
happen I ask congressional leaders what
they think the president meant by adding
to the deal they said they're not sure
perhaps he's referring to executive
action but the deal is the deal it's not
changing they want to hold the first
vote by tonight and they need to pass it
in the house the Senate and get it to
the President's desk for his signature
by Friday night gale if they want to
avert another partial government
shutdown and nobody wants that appears
to be moving in the right direction
Thank You Nancy we shall see